somebody on Reddit asked a pretty
interesting question I don't know if you
have an interesting answer to it what
makes a chess move quote unquote human
as you are someone oh this is to me but
it's matching you in third person as you
are someone working in AI this idea of
humanness would seem incredibly
interesting yes sir it is especially
since most cheat detection relies on
humanness as a way to detect cheaters I
think since children being born right
now will have the advantage of engine
training their whole life they will
start to see the game the way an engine
does will a person be considered a
cheater if they play like an engine
there also seem to be a discrepancy
especially with Levy about who can play
What appears to be a non-human move he
often says things like quote if you were
a normal player
normally in quotes if you were a normal
player I would think you were cheating
but since it's Magnus
I don't doubt Magnus is great but if
humanness is our Benchmark what is the
ELO rating where your moves can start to
look like an engine without critique
there's a bunch of questions in there
they combine two of my quotes yes and
into one so one thing that I like to say
is sometimes in a chess game moves look
or an opening looks so ridiculous that
if a viewer played it I would make fun
of them or slap them that's always the
joke if I was your chess coach I'd smack
you but yeah when Magnus plays it was oh
wow you know it's a very different so
they mixed up this quote with another
quote which is uh
you know if if ice if
I'll be explaining something and I'll
say oh and here the engine says you
should play like this yeah if one of
your opponents plays like this report
them for cheating they say they fuse two
quotes they said oh human can't play
like that but because it's an engine
move but because Magnus is playing so
they they mixed kind of two things but
there's interesting
levels of humor and uh insight there on
both of those yeah the difference
between human move and engine and like
what an engine move is
is I think two things number one a
computer move
is outlandish in its in its concept and
it's
um and its idea
so the best example that I can give of
that is if you gave a hundred grand
Masters a position and told them you
know what what do you think the best
move here is for black not in this
position right here we have nothing but
an overwhelming amount of them would
look at the position evaluate everything
they know about the game of chess which
is relatively similar but obviously
slightly imbalanced based on their skill
level and they would come up with a
sample size of two or three moves and in
comes the computer with a [ __ ]
Haymaker
and suddenly everybody goes
oh everything we know about Chess has
gone out the window so they all start
looking at that move and they know it's
the best move so now they start adding
the evidence behind
the verdict as opposed to getting to the
verdict while first looking at at the
evidence
so the concept of it and the idea of it
is so outlandish based on a certain type
of position that you can't fully grasp
it you have to continue to beg the
engine to tell you what the variation is
a move is only good if its extension is
good that's the way chess works so if
like a move is good it's because the
computer has seen that the various
branches of things going forward are
also good so you bring all that back and
no human could have even conceptualized
that initial thing but the second thing
about computer moves is they they look
counterintuitive so
that's a if you might be in a position
where it looks like the demands of the
position are ABC and then the computer
is like nope it's not because I've seen
the future way more than you possibly
could have and I don't have emotions
so like dumb moves and Brilliant moves
can look similar yes and oftentimes do